everybody's gonna be asking about the
sex scene in the movie is there a sexy
there is an amazing sexy melissa rauch
wrote the most crazy epic gymnastics sex
scene ever in her new comedy LeBron's
no really that's what she wrote we knew
that those characters were gonna get
together at that point in the script but
then we got to like plugging in the
dialogue we looked up at each other from
our laptops like oh of course is what
these characters to do these two
world-class gymnast this is what would
happen when they got together so we
ended up writing into the script the
most crazy epic gymnastics Exene ever
and it was in bold with underlines and
like tons of exclamation points you know
literally some yeah and then sort of
bullet pointed what those things would
be it's the closest that I will get to
ever writing a porno I won't close any
doors on myself but yeah I'm not just
I'm not a lock myself in it right all
right Sebastian Stan stars with Melissa
in the amazingly choreographed sequence
everyone will be talking about yeah so I
had a phenomenal Cirque de Soleil
performer who is my body double as did
Sebastian you're seeing a lot of
Sebastian in this movie he really he
really went for it
I can tell you right now there's two
parts in that whole sequence what that
is not me I didn't have enough time to
learn how to do the problem horse and
nor that I have enough time to actually
stretch my leg I was thinking that lock
yes I mean if I had maybe another month
or two I would have just gone for I
don't even know it was just so
ridiculous yeah you have to
you